morale is kind of like the trees of a
forest they're just the backbone of a
whole tropical ecosystem and if they
disappear were in a lot of trouble my
name is Kenny de Meyer I'm the founder
of the coral restoration foundation the
reason I'm doing this I was been growing
up diving spent a lot of time in the
water at lunch two three
I basically watched the coral reefs
dying as the reefs died the fish didn't
come back and I realized I'm tired of
watching it die I need to do something
about it and so I developed this whole
idea of growing corals in an offshore
nursery and replanting them on the reef
so you're kind of like a farmer I'm a
farmer
yeah we grow corals just like a farm
there's a good time of the year to plant
and there's a harvest time and we have
five offshore nurseries in the keys each
tree can hold 100 corals we start with
little fragments that we collect and
after six to nine months maybe a year
that fragment has turned into a colony
that might have a hundred centimeters of
growth on it we cut that off and then we
plant it out on the reef
so we just harvested some corals and
we're going to take them out to Pickles
reef right now and plant them we've got
a couple thousand of them out there that
we've already planted and we've add some
more
it is a bit of gardening when you put
the corals back out on the reef you're
saying yeah I think that would look nice
over there and that would look nice over
there and some of its based on what used
to be there and what should be there and
that's how we do our planting we planted
twenty thousand already this year
we'll plant twenty-five thousand next
year those corals will probably spawn
next year part of the long-range goals
get the corals reproducing on their own
I'm excited every time I get in the
water whether I'm going to work in the
nursery or whether I'm planting corals
or just looking for new areas to plant a
lot of people said oh you can never do
that it'll never work can't do it on a
big enough scale and I think I've proven
that that can be done and if we can
train enough people and teach enough
people in other places I think we can
really see a significant turnaround
another day another twirl
you